let's talk about it out of the gate how
does it feel to be returning after all
this time did you think the show would
ever come back i actually did
know that the show was going to come
back
and the reason why
is i had i spoke to a psychic in 2013
and she told me
many things that came true
including the return of the show
almost to the day seven or eight years
later wild yep and i can't give out the
number because
she then she would have time for me so
listen i just love that you started it
with i did know because i have a psychic
it feels like that's something i would
say great and i just felt it within me i
just like how could you not have miami
housewives right
did you have any hesitations coming back
this time
maybe a little bit but for the most part
i you know just i'm human so i was in my
head a little bit like do i want to go
back into this do i not but ultimately
of course i've been dreaming and wishing
you know to come back for the last eight
years just like all of the fans and
everyone that made noise and helped us
come back
well there's in the teaser there's a lot
of partying
there's a lot of fighting there's some
kissing
what can you tease what can you tell us
that we didn't see in that trailer i
don't know if this is going to make it
like i had a mini
mental breakdown at one point um
that i couldn't control and that was
really difficult for me because i like
to be in control of my emotions and
um
you know the the cameras were at this
point when we were filming this specific
episode
you could not get away from
the cameras there was no hiding so
it was super raw and unfiltered just
like it always is but in this moment in
particular
um
you'll see that when something like that
happens because life does happen and the
cameras are everywhere
in that moment what is that like for you
when you're having that really raw
natural moment for you and there happens
to be cameras around producers
and other housewives
at the moment i just wanted to crawl
into a hole and just hide sure but there
was nowhere to run in this particular
episode
and you have to tune in to see what i'm
talking about i don't want to give too
much away but it was one of those
scenes or places where there was nowhere
to run and there was nowhere to hide
but you're doing okay right
i'm fine yeah
moment you know we're human we all have
moments where
we're not doing so well and i i had one
of those moments for sure in true
canadian fashion you're regarded as one
of the nice housewives um
in that universe and we love that when
you think about moments that have been
filmed is there anything that you're
kind of cringing at or that you're
hoping won't make it
most of it
i'm cringing at so much it's so
we get the episodes a little bit before
everyone else and
i can't even watch it with my friends or
even my husband or anyone like maybe
i'll watch it with my two-year-old
daughter because she has no idea she's
just like mommy so
um i i am just like on the edge of my
seat like oh my god what am i what am i
doing what am i saying uh so it's it's
like i'm on the edge of my seat and i
was in it so you can imagine
everyone else which makes me think too
when you're in these moments and you
have a husband you have a partner you
have children does a lot of that play in
your mind with
how you're reacting to situations
because once the season airs there's
ramifications for all of you outside of
that season
does that play in your mind at all
of course of course you know i you need
to try to not be your head
while you're filming and just be who you
are um because you want it to be organic
and and you want it to be real which it
is yeah but of course there's a part of
me
that's thinking how is this all going to
play out how is this going to look
um
yeah
yeah for sure
yeah um
in addition to some new ladies there
there's some ladies who've been there
before do you find that it's nice to
have a fresh new slate or that there are
still some things that you sort of have
to deal with
uh it's nice to not be the newbie that
was fun because yeah gee so
um
i've actually i've met kiki she's a
friend of i've known her for years i
actually
like and enjoy
all of them
um
which not all of the women do so
sometimes i think they they feel i'm
maybe kind of playing both sides but i'm
not i just if i vibe with somebody
i'm gonna go with that i'm not gonna
fight that and i'm not gonna make up a
fight or drama that's not there
um
but it's super surprising to see who i
do get into it with
oh okay very good your life has changed
so much since the last time we saw you
on the show are there parts of your life
that you kind of wish that you could
keep private or do you let it all go
there's absolutely parts of my life that
i wish i could keep private but i signed
up for the show
this is what i signed up for
so i have to go to these places even
though it's uncomfortable for me um
we got to give the people what they want
there is the new ultimate girls trip so
i ask you who would you want to go on an
ultimate girls trip with in the real
housewives universe and who would you
like to maybe leave on the island
i think i would want to go with the
women that i know
because they're familiar to me yeah um i
think kim zolciak because i know her
personally she's a friend i love her
um
kenya i also know kenya i think just
the women i know from the other shows i
would want to go on a girls trip with
them just because i know them
growing up in canada would you ever ever
imagine that this is where your your
life would end up that you'd be on such
a hit franchise like this
again i'm gonna sound crazy but another
psychic stop no
no
another psychic
told my best friend that i
would live in the states
and
i would be on a soap opera
which is kind of like that right
so and i that's what i was pursuing
acting and modeling
um and i i even did say on one of the
other uh like season two or three in one
of my interviews that i always knew i
was gonna marry a plastic surgeon isn't
that wild
maybe i'm psychic
maybe you're psychic and i want the name
of your psychics that's it that's a
different psyche but it's just crazy how
and then you know you start to believe
what the psychics say and maybe that has
something to do with the two the power
of suggestions
yeah
right definitely well either way
congratulations on everything and can't
wait to watch
thank you so much
you